von hebel
[Musique]
[Rires]
yao luce l'auvergnat soulèvent ces 280
kg c'est un coupeur
[Musique]
serment la voix d'or puisqu'elle a voir
mais les casses
daniel à l'heure de viande aussi
en verlan us et bob bobby 62 ans ancien
lutteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le chez les verts sont dit oui sous la
brise fait toujours son petit cooper
avec lui c'est daniel fried
[Musique]
m
venise
les biya - jack et puis le petit
personnel de la maison
vous inquiète employés de chef pourra
servir une serveuse
[Musique]
3pour
il a passé
la mécanique
ah oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une ville dans la ville
le même âge que notre dame puis cendres
800 ans qu'elle porte ce nom les halles
[Musique]
accompagné par ceux de saint denis et de
saint-honoré 800 ans qu'elle hurle sa
ritournelle de marchands et d'animaux
cas la réponse en odeur l'odeur de la
sueur de paris avec le crottin et le
poisson le cerfeuil et laviolette les
fruits qui pourrissent à midi clos sans
levain 800 ans que cette ville dans la
ville ne dors pas la nuit
et
[Musique]
marçais
il ya beaucoup de fantômes dans les
lames ici par exemple sous la bourse de
commerce celui de la lobo sous la halle
au blé
le fantôme de l'hôtel de soissons des
rennes et des filles des moines et des
alchimistes et c'est ainsi partout dans
le quartier les halles déborde de
fantômes surtout elles ont toujours
débordé de vie de bonheur mille route
ils aboutissent route du blé donnant à
la rue de la ferronnerie route du dragon
à la rue saint-denis route du poisson de
la mer du nord au faubourg poissonnière
et c'est au croisement de cette ruée de
cette bousculade que marchands et
artisans et leur corporation
roy et dames de la riche et paul vont
former l'espèce vraiment à part
klopp le des halles qui nous avaient
c'est aussi de nos maisons et qui a
toujours vécu dort dans la rue dans les
cours en histoire et dans le courant des
noms n'ont pas ici à sens d'organes
allez ça va
samba terminaux s'emballe seulement avec
deux shoots
oui ma chérie oui ma chérie alors la
seule à présenter un camarade s'est
apprêté qui va t'expliquer un peu tôt
pour secure eux
et puis
comment ça se porte
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans un an quand ce sable tourné au sous
sol des frigos cette machine à faire le
froid alors on peut dire que l'homme de
la viande dernière incarnation de
l'homme des halles ne sera plus car on
ne peut pas imaginer son caractère son
langage sa vie en dehors de cette ville
dans la ville
on les imagine pas ailleurs michel
hubert auguste le cantal où robert
herlant fernand la voix d'or jacques lé
sabreuses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les encombrements urbains mais bouchon
c'est ici leur berceau
ici la patrie de l'injure du chartier
pour une raison bien simple
jamais les halles dont il a sept places
regardez les bien c'est tripier ses
douches et ses bonheurs de viande et une
pavillon qu'ils sont encore loin
regardez là comme les derniers produits
d'une espèce qui va disparaître à jamais
eu et les mines petits métiers serrés
les uns contre les autres et qui les ont
toujours entouré petit mercier petit
panier de charles d'orléans marchande
herbeux riz et plus près de nous
marchand de feuilles de fougères pour
envelopper le poisson est copieuse de
poids et courageuse de grenouilles
marchant sous pains et de café à 5
centimes réveilleur nocturne marchande
d'arlequin qui vend sous ce joli nom les
détritus achetés aux cuisines des pires
gargotes et puis toutes sortes de
regrattiers l'endroit et généreux comme
sous la table de gargantua les déchets
ils sont recherchés
les pauvres le ca
je vais en mettre votre famille était
venue d'alsace
quant à ce dossier peut oser on est
décidés de 71 et alors mon grand père a
commencé mon grand père c'est à dire le
père de mon père mon grand père a
commencé par rendre au panier et ben
vous au panier s'était il acheté sous
les ailes il faisait des rachats et
vendez dans la rue au panier par petits
morceaux
c'est comme ça quand on a débuté dans la
famille violent ce moment-là qu'est ce
que c'est l atmosphère d aller on avait
madame ans faire d elle s'était
inquiétée encore plus formidable je
comprends vous le dire parce que je suis
43 ans
mais enfin c'était d'après des anciens
c'était formidable c'était un mouvement
de monde il y avait le pont de
l'histoire de la corde avant l'histoire
de l'accord c'était autrefois les galets
les porteurs ils avaient eu leur est
alors ils allaient retirer 10 années
dans l'est dans les bistrots ni les
diables et puis les autres et alors
comme c'était pour ainsi dire des
courges ans il dormait le soir sur une
corde
debout sur une table et les bras croisés
et le maquereau mariné le matin le gaz
coupé la corde il avait payé dessous
pour dormir comme south un sou est il
allé loin un bouillon ou un boeuf à la
fifa les ficelles des morceaux de boeuf
qui tirait d'une marine adriano je sais
que y'a mahmoud quand des risques et aux
seychelles après elle en a tiré un
morceau de viande août qui tirent à bout
d'os c'était au petit maintenant
poursuivie tout à l'heure hubert
l'histoire devant montagny vous aviez
par exemple dans certains points où
comme dans le xvième il vendait que des
rosbifs un bon morceau et
dans les bars dans les comtés de
montmartre dans sept mois il ne vendait
que de la base du poteau lors ces gens
là descend bay de mon art avec les
rosbifs qui vont défendre 16e et
reprenait au boucher de la base qui
revendait du côté mon maman c'est quoi
la c'est ce qu'on appelle la compagnie
australienne chose qui est très bien
aussi monsieur voltaire c'est une chose
qu'on a pas parlé ce les marchands de
frites et les marchands de bouillon
qu'il y avait dans le temps tu t'en
rappelles toi de la rechange bouillon
qui passe et les primevères et
souffraient les chauffeurs et les
grilles des chauffeurs les gens qui vont
arriver là il avait des petites
chaufferette il mettait de la braise et
pour les caissières à l'aso faits soient
les pieds ou les mains sur le carreau
n'importe où parce que y'avait rien de
couvrir 1 est bien entouré mais il ya
d'être votre fruit de l'effort qu'ils se
trouvent les pyramides de fiable le
souffleur tous les bottes de poireaux
ranger l'alliance appelle et acer et
asus et acer
c'est des choses qui n'existent pas un
juge ou me dit maintenant arrivés en
caisse ou un numéro un calibre vous
savez c'est et c'était joli à voir
ce concerne pyramide de chou-fleur il y
en avait point qu'ils dépensaient
c'était une pyramide qui dès demain
oui les domaines comme un fromage de
deux chaises
j'ai passé ma vie est derrière moi je
passais ma vie j'avais jamais regretté
sue lg raymond
ma grand mère qui se soulève ma grand
mère partage elle avait 20 ans elle part
fait livrer la ville evrard l'asile de
vie d'evra et elle promet dans la côte
d'anjou moins à cheval d'orgueil parce
que pas les livrer à vie d'evra nou pa
bi l'erreur père et vaucluse il fallait
livrer à cinquante mètres une femme tout
seul quand à 30 du matin une voiture
[Musique]
m
dès le début du 19e siècle en 1830 déjà
on songe à faire partir le marché de
gros qui s'entend plus tard et le
premier centre d'alimentation du monde
nourrissant paris est le dixième des
français autour du carreau on n'arrête
pas de s'entasser rives cpo négociants
et cole porter jeunes ou vieux on y
vient aussi respirer un air de liberté
comme dans un port de mer et personne ne
vous demande de vous venez au reste les
conditions de logement sont déplorables
les mais hambourg et marchandises
tout se dégrade au lendemain de la
dernière guerre les halles sont à bout
de force mais touché wall c'est toucher
au centre historique de paris aussi
faudra-t-il attendre 25 ans 25 ans de
discussions de polémiques d'appréhension
le transfert du marché de gros hors de
paris est dessiné en 1946 les marchés
d'intérêt nationaux de la villette et de
rungis seront instituées en 1959
l'action du général de gaulle est alors
déterminante c'est lui qui nomme
monsieur libère bout commissaire au
transfert des halles dix ans plus tard
en 1969 les fruits et légumes vont à
rungis
les pavillons de baltard sont
irrémédiablement condamné en avril 1971
[Musique]
c'est au même mois d'avril 1971 que se
situe au pavillon 6 au dessus de la
triperie un événement tout à fait
singulier venue de nice des camions
dépose des caisses dont un homme
surveille de déchargement il s'appelle
raymond moretti
c'est un peintre et cette fois il a
besoin d espace
il y a dans ses caisses des mains et des
ventres des soleils et des jardins les
machines et des jouets les fragments
d'un univers
en avril 1971 débarque aux halles la
partie visible de l'oeuvre de raymond
moretti
c'est au même printemps 71 que les
promeneurs découvrent le quartier des
halles est ce à cause de sa dégradation
ou à cause du groupement de la vie dans
ses rues on a l'impression d'ouvrir les
yeux pour la première fois sur des
architectures mystérieuse des espaces
des voûtes de pierres et de fer des
hommes on s'aperçoit que les pavillons
est quittée par les maraîchers en 1969
sont des palais de lumière des espaces
précieux alors pendant deux ans des
faits extraordinaires vont s'y déployer
en liberté peintures sculptures cinéma
théâtre pour ses derniers feux de joie
des halles il y aura un million de
visiteurs
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
le départ des fruits et légumes avaient
été deux ans plus tôt le commencement de
la fin des as tandis que le marché de la
viande
bush écrit priez volaille demeurait
provisoirement dans les quatre pavillons
ouest au petit matin du 28 février 1969
les marchés des fruits légumes fleurs
beurre oeufs et fromages ainsi que celui
du poisson quittait définitivement le
carreau des halles pour rungis
[Musique]
aux halles de paris 15 hectares ici à
rungis deux ans
or juillet 1971 sous les halles
centrales
l'architecte fernand pouillon nous a
parlé de l'architecte victor baltard
baltard et décharger des halles comme
lorsque la brousse est chargé de la
bibliothèque sainte geneviève
ils ont fait une avant tout à fait
originale qui sortait pour la première
fois dimitri du classicisme de la
construction en pierre de la
construction en architecture c'est un
grand novateur
c'est un grand novateur et c'est un
homme qui malheureusement a été un point
de départ et qui n'a pas été suivi par
la suite du fait que la structure s'est
en procès
un site après lui et que nous ne sommes
pas sortis encore des moyens qu'avaient
les égyptiens ou des grecs les romains
pour construire et conseillons toujours
comme des malgré le béton malgré tout ça
c'est une chanson toujours en lourd
alors que baltard avait imaginé des
jalles architecture industrielle à base
d'acier qui étaient légères qui était
facile à consommer que pouvait elle son
disque réalisé il semblerait que le
respect conservateur des constructeurs
de cette époque là à gagner sur sur la
sur les inventions de balle tu as de la
brousse suivre les et que leur vote n'a
pas été poursuivi il ya eu un grand
espoir dans l'architecturé à ce moment
là qui n'a pas été poursuivi et c'est
très important car
l' architecture est le seul pour la
seule industrie de cela
le qui ne soit pas de son temps
nous sommes des millions dans une époque
avec une architecture qui étaient en
retard d'un siècle
elle rit elle devrait redémarrer à la
bourse et à baltard c'est en cela que
bataille est un grand homme c'est un
c'est un grand plasticien à 6 c'est un
homme qui précise pas souhaité que les
les
proportion harmonique d'une façon
merveilleuse tous les hangars de bâtard
sont sur le nombre d'or sur les
proportions harmonie c'est une oeuvre
délicieuse à l'occasion de bâtiment
utilitaire chez des étrangers t2 1971
dans les ruines de baltard passe la
silhouette d'un peintres du xxème siècle
c'est toujours la nuit que travaillerai
membres utile au pavillon 6 dont il a la
clé l'oeuvre se déploie lentement
cette nuit encore il a rendez vous avec
elle
[Musique]
à la même heure le travail commence pour
robert herlant 62 ans ancien lutteur et
son camarade auguste le cantal où deux
hommes qui dépasse largement le quintal
ils vont rejoindre dans leur travail le
patron michel hubert jimmy choo et
fernand lavoie donne il est une heure du
matin il y a déjà deux heures qui
réveillait cette ville dans la ville
voici le monde énorme de la boucherie
déjà deux heures que la ronde des fêtes
louis qui a commencé autour des camions
la porte la viande de plus de 50
départements français mais aussi des
pays bas du danemark ce qui vient de se
mettre en marche ici c'est une grande
machine un système compliqué très
anciens très précis dans la division du
travail dans la hiérarchie 28 postes
mandataires des hommes en noir
mandataire vendeurs d'autres en blanc
homme de ménage cooper comique plateau
porter indépendant payer de 3,5 centimes
le kilo transporté en cas d'erreur ou de
mes comptes et spécialiste est là pour
trancher
on l'appelle le litige heures certains
mandataires détiennent par héritage les
crochets à viande de leur travail mais
leurs ancêtres les détenaient en vertu
de privilèges accordés par les rois de
france
autant les bouchers se couronner de rose
le jour de la saint-andré leur patron et
paient de belles messes à saint-eustache
ces hommes qui vivront demain dans les
ordinateurs appartiennent à un milieu
très fermé traditionalistes loi de
l'offre et de la demande
discussion à l'orientale de bouche à
oreille système de relations très
personnelle entre mandataire et clients
fournisseurs avec repas rencontre
fidélité dans les rapports dans la
travée une ambiance familiale avec de
petits avantages
pas de grève en même temps un travail
très rigoureux car sous la travée on se
fait à la main ou à dos d'homme ainsi
entre l'arrivée la vente les 10 tonnes
d'une travée sont déplacés quatre fois
total 40 tomes ce que des places en une
nuit
l'équipe de michel hubert
tout sera différent pour eux dans un an
quand ils auront quitté les halles les
sombres guichet vieux de plus d'un
siècle les caves de baltard l'odeur de
tribe
il n'y aura plus de ruisseaux de sang
qui sèchent rue berger le matin près des
paniers de persil
le
l'or
elle même avec du trafic et j'ai été
témoin du congo cavaliers ben moi c'est
moi je vous mangez janin foot
au juste mon ambition c'est d'être fort
des halles la rabine où ça c'est quand
j'aime chez toi la ville du cantal à sa
belle
pourquoi est ce que tu voulais trop fort
parce que physiquement je me forçais
quoi effectivement j'ai forcé j'aime
bien me dépenser celui que tu as rêvé
s'est porté le maximum et j'ai aidé moi
je les copains il pas plus peut dire la
même
faut le faire et alors la détente dans
le cantal quand il retrouve ses j'ai
fait 300 kilos donc entendus ici et j'ai
fait un essai il ya il ya deux ans j'ai
fait un essai j'ai pas réussi parce que
j'étais tout seul
premièrement si le vt avec des camarades
le travail automatiquement
j'aurais peut-être améliorer peut-être
parce que j'y monte à 300 kg
malheureusement ce que je me suis
je me suis arrêté au bout de trente
mètres et puis je me suis arrêté comme
ça mais n'empêche je balance et le sac
de monter dans le camion et le camion
qui fait la largeur un copain qui les
attends je vais t'aider goût de même 18
pas la peine
savent plus trop des rhéobus que tous
les deux vous travaillez en chambre à
faire là tous les cinq ans
comment ça se passe un camp où travaille
ensemble on discute m coup on aime bien
rien après travail après le travail mais
dans le travail on part on est habitués
comme ça on papa dans le travail non
agréé qui a la taille parce que c'est
tellement un travail tellement elles
sont patents se distraire parce que les
désaxés la ferme aux railleries que tu
nous parles d'une chose maintenant on
est ici à un an du départ peut-être les
conditions de travail ici qu'est ce que
c'était en demande précise des
conditions de travail les conditions de
travail des conditions d'hygiène etc
comment ça s'est passé ici j'espère que
ce sera mieux là où parce que si nous en
bien une douche ici à des douches rien
et ainsi douche mais il faut aimer
vanter guerre qui oppose déjà rien de
bon ne palliera nous mêmes même façon un
vestiaire et des chauffeurs oui il faut
faire du neuf
et alors est ce qu il arrive que
quelqu'un se placer par exemple ça peut
arriver à zéro téléphoné à bali togo
n'est pas une infirmerie sur toi non non
il ya une boîte de secours là l'as roma
bien c'est tout une boîte de secourir en
ce monde si quelqu'un scoop une main
jusqu'au pain doit maintenant que
c'était déjà arrivé
ah non moi je vais était bien sûr un
coût mais c'était vers il est sinon ma
foi tant de discours du yen va faire ses
doigts d'un 7e réunion est arrivé qu'il
ait les accents des fois ils peuvent
compenser les deux camions anti guerre
mais charrie tout alors venez nombreux
m
[Musique]
de plus mercredi
/
[Musique]
3 6 3
ok
[Applaudissements]
ouais je vais parler oui bralo bressuire
c'est jack au projet de penser les
moyennes at en bouche fort à temps il
entraîne
alors que les lois 1180
la 2 860
[Musique]
le 3150
m
à personne la vente et tracteurs et
méchant dans les verres
ça fait combien de la chanson prendre
l'ascendant
cette fois en librairie ce projet photo
l'air bien bricolo nous il est toutefois
tous les trois ans les combats début
quand j'ai connu de tous les grands j'ai
rencontré les champions du monde de tout
fait j'ai rencontré des jeunes j'étais
son partenaire aussi j'ai rencontré
boulot j'étais son partenaire deux ans
dans un cirque a évolué c'est moi et
rigolo qui avons amené le 4 temps
schirck à travers la france parce que le
catch exister à paris à cette époque là
et après on l'a promené un peu partout
pour faire voir le catch à temps viendra
c'est chez moi le premier partenaire et
gulu bas je suis nouvelle par hasard
comme ça parce que ça me plaisait plus
de voyager comme j'avais voyagé pendant
une vingtaine d'années
je suis un sédentaire moi j'aime bien
rester chez moi temps qui les a vus
et voilà mais j'ai eu un bon souvenir
parce qu'elle a lus de sa forme des
hommes c'est un vrai sport mais la lutte
l'adulte ça veut dire un mot qui est
dans le dictionnaire on se dit qu'est ce
que vous disiez sur la lutte à l'essai
du bonheur 11 heures du matin
les hommes de la viande ont fini leur
journée et le sens de la triperie à
sécher dans le ruisseau de la rue berger
vraiment mort et y revient dans le
mystérieux pavillon 6 le contenu des
caisses débarquer au printemps est en
place sur ses instructions
trois compagnons niçois ont ajusté les
12 tonnes de matériaux divers acier voix
formica tableau intégrer l'univers de
moretti nébuleuse fantastique qui recule
les limites et du temps et de l'espace
l'oeuvre n'est pas terminée elle ne le
sera jamais on pourrait le croire
atteindre la folie des grandeurs c'est
le sens de la grandeur qu'il possède et
que je lis ou est de rendre visible à
tous disait jean cocteau en assistant à
la naissance de l'oeuvre sans nom elle
sera poursuivie jusqu'à la fin de la vie
de son auteur
arbre qui pousse avec lui et deviendra
une forêt aux besoins aussi vaste que le
quartier où que la ville
ainsi à l'heure où dans le ventre de
paris disparaît un monde une planète du
futur atterri sur les halles morte elle
est visible on dirais même qu'elle voit
et qu elle nous regarde
[Musique]
il
les halles sont mortes maisons murées
boutiques vides attendent à venir depuis
des années l'avenir il est sur un plan
un plan qui évite le pire
pas de construction à la surface du
carreau mais les six pavillons s de
baltard a battu pour permettre la
construction à ciel ouvert de la plus
grande station de métro du monde produit
par l'atelier parisien d'urbanisme est
votée en juillet 1969 après 12 ans de
discussions ce plan le voici
on ne reconnaît plus que l'église
saint-eustache
sur ce plan définitif du quartier des
halles trois éléments essentiels
un grand espace qui doit être planté en
sous sol un espace qualifié d' un mot
rom forum est en dessous encore la
station du rer le métro express régional
raccordé à la ligne de sault double
station qui fut il faut le souligner un
élément déterminant du plan actuellement
l'ua arrive à peu près au niveau de la
bourse
leurs bras rejoindre la gare de lyon
alors le rer à faire un tracé de cette
nature et se poursuit ainsi ce sont les
pavillons actuelle sur les prévisions
actuelles des halles alors que la ligne
de ceux-là aussi très grossièrement
remontent pas selon m à bien se
raccorder ou rer le croisera et un jour
ira
par conséquent les stations se trouvent
à 7 à cet emplacement
et pourquoi ne pas faire le contraire à
battre les quatre pavillons ouest copie
de baltard pour les remplacer par un
jardin devant saint-eustache sauver les
six pavillons originaux alès construire
enfin la station de métro sous le
plateau beaubourg ou sous le boulevard
sébastopol telle est l'idée soumise au
public au musée des arts décoratifs par
des associations de quartier au
printemps 71
pourquoi vous signez
des promoteurs viennent s'installer dans
les gammes et
comme un peu partout dans paris ne plus
supporter certains pavillons doivent
rester et qu'une rénovation des halles
qui n'ont pas la situation qu'on fait
des allées vous avez aussi peur de
l'avenir n'ont pas peur de l'avenir j'ai
peur que les promeneurs ce soit des
immeubles qui viennent à la place j'ai
entendu à la radio et je peux vous
demander monsieur pourquoi vous pourquoi
vous signez quelle est votre opinion le
sentiment sur cette décision
côté j'aime beaucoup les clients de
baltard et depuis un certain temps si
j'ai pas attendu et contrairement à ce
que dit monsieur l'hygiène qu'on fasse
du bruit autour pour apprécier ce
quartier et ensuite je considère que
pratiquement la seule raison pour
laquelle on détruit les halles de
baltard c'est de faire des économies en
construisant une station à ciel ouvert
alors qu'il serait possible affaire
souterraines comme on l'a fait partout
ailleurs et
on pourrait parfaitement conservé les
podiums valent pas tous tous bourde
évidemment en dépensant un peu plus
d'argent dans pas français je suis pas
tout à fait
connaissant de tout ça mais je ne suis
pas toujours pour la préservation mais
dans ce cas je suis pour la préservation
des reines
un américain de grande deux en or in
line et acheteurs après ma visite hier
soir avec monsieur dit bolt
le préfet a dit à la presse que le train
est en marche et rien ne peut plus
l'arrêter mais pour moi ce n'est pas
trop tard demain j'ai rendez vous avec
monsieur le ministre des affaires
culturelles
je discuterai avec lui j'essaierai de
voir s'il est véritablement certain que
la france accepte de voir jeter à la
poubelle un trésor français qui
appartient aussi au patrimoine mondial
de la culture monsieur event m'avait
offert un pavillon dessiné par baltard
qui se trouve à l'heure actuelle à la
villette
[Rires]
auryn rhein parviendra-t-il à emmener
les pavillons aux états unis rien n'est
moins sûr lorsqu'il a reçu hier monsieur
jacques duhamel n'a laissé que peu
d'espoir aux milliardaires américains
pour celui-ci maintenant sa dernière
chance être reçu par le président de la
république
cette rencontre n'aura pas lieu
et c'est au mois d'août 1971 dans le
pari un peu vite des vacances que l'on
commence à démolir les parapluies de
baltard les six pavillons de l'est il
faut qu'ils soient rasés pour la
toussaint
on va commencer alors à creuser c'est la
deuxième étape la construction de la
station de métro
enfin dernière étape au dessus du métro
le forum en sous sol mais éclairé par
des puits de jour selon la formule
officielle 80000 personnes au moins s'y
rencontreront aux heures de pointe
nous serons en 1976 une certitude
rien ne sera construit en surface sur la
plus grande partie de cet espace une
incertitude à quoi ressembleront le
centre de commerce international et les
autres building qui pourrait remplacer
la bourse de commerce dans le voisinage
immédiat de saint-eustache
[Musique]
auguste le mental au travail à quelques
jours robert qui fut lutins yves jacques
le symbole sans compter mon récit
monsieur pouillon aussi et le dû de
bouffon et fernand lavoie tort
le site est bien rincer la dalle sous
mais voilà qu'elle se font
à mal les
art enchères et marquise héloïse et
denise ont quitté saint-eustache et le
rouge qui tâche elle
mais trop tôt
là
jean jacques rousseau
elle se coucher trop tard la rue 8h
baltes
ne s'était bien rincer la terre
le sou
voulait
mais
à laquelle ce fonds
à mal les a
adieu baltard adieu les petits matins
adieu mes nuits sur le carreau et la rue
rambuteau
dans parfum des oignons
des rognons des trognons il faisait bon
s'asseoir au fond d'un abreuvoir
le c'était bien lancée
la tête
le sou
ou les
mais voilà qu'elle se font
les
j'ai presque sûr que l'on va hâter les
halles raté de l'occasion idéale parce
tombe à envahir le terrain libre et
qu'on va exploiter d'une façon
individuelle et spéculative
l'environnement
on amène une station de métro ici avait
pas gênante
n empêche pas de garder un terrain
vierge on peut très bien bâtir dessus
sur en veut on peut faire ce qu'il veut
avec un sur une autre je pense que le
fait bien c'est sûr mais toi c'est
surtout sa construction d'après ce que
je comprends qu'ils aient pas un
problème mais ça son utilité est
incontestable elle n'est pas chez nous
seulement elle va amener une population
importante oil qui sont en quoi des
employés de bureau surtout nous
employons magasin devant magasin que va
devenir le quartier des halles des
bureaux des grands magasins ce sera un
abcès de fixation et puis des maisons
bourgeoises pour gens riches et les
halles sont ratés parce que nancy sera
mal et ça je le pressens ge le prévoit
pas ce que je sais sur quel plan
administratif si cela se font
suffisamment d'habitude on vous a vu
faire ça et je sais que ça va marcher
comme je le dis
je suis un avec espoir parce que
voyez vous je ne voudrais pas être un
mauvais un mauvais prophète moi
j'aimerais j'aimerais en revanche pour
parler d'enthousiasmé je veux toujours
proposer une solution tout zias chose
j'aimerais en revanche que les ânes soin
de soi le
là le l'opinion s'est intéressée de
façon spéciale parce que c'est idéal qui
a concerné davantage des parisiens et je
mourrai et crean soit un test de la
lutte de l'opinion contre les saloperies
que l'on commet partout ça le bruit
toute l'humanité contre l'âme des hommes
contre l'enfance contre la jeunesse
c'est vraiment affreux des récents entre
manipule l'homme à notre époque dans les
cités que l'on construit alors si les
halles réussissent et si vous
réussissiez à changer ce mouvement à ce
que réalise au contraire une chose
exaltante en deux pour une fois en
france ils se trouvaient des gens qui
étaient assez courageux pour dire et
pour le faire à ce moment là on dirait
peut-être ailleurs on va recommencer
et ça ce serait un grand moment
les travaux vont durer cinq ans il faut
donc attendre au moins jusque là pour
savoir avec certitude ce que sera le
quartier des halles
[Musique]
tout cela disent pas mort se produit
donc voilà ce fut toute une aussi quand
même quelques générations qui disparaît
et c'est une vie une vie familiale qu'on
avait entre autres on était tous des
amis tous des copains ah non ça sera
plus pareil on ne sera plus des amis
comme dans le temps c'était nous c'était
notre petite vie on vivait la nuit où
vivait le jour on en s'en aller à deux
trois heures la famille on se réunissait
on allait voir les copains on faisait un
petit gueuleton single pensez vous
voulez on mangeait ensemble on se
raconte nos petites nos petites
histoires c'est tout mais là bon ça sera
c'est la machine de la machine et puis
ça c'est plus nous c'est une heure on
tire un trait aux gens qu'on partir en
tirant très élaborés comme des bestiaux
où comme des rats partout moi c'est
comme ça maintenant je vais prêter ouais
j'ai bien peur que ça ça sera le
conditionnement exactement pour ça a
conditionné la thérapie de paysans à
suivre la piste où les vingt minutes je
ne pensais pas la question ça c'est des
petites histoires système américain on
sera numérotée d'aillon elle est déjà ça
commence messieurs alamo
[Musique]
ça fait dix sept avants et fiancée avec
moment montréal s'en aille
ah oui faire un mariage dans la
tradition se mettre ce grandiose
oui on met dans des petits tonneaux sur
chaque table parce que pourquoi s'il
faut servir c'est pas possible tu y
tenons sur chaque d'aller chacun
serviable et puis on va aller la mairie
provient puisque mu 1 défendu premier
j'arrive au liban dans une forêt une
couronne de fleurs d'oranger parce que
pour m après sur une plage comme ça se
faisait comme ça se fait enfin dix sept
ans la femme fleur d'oranger sont
peut-être après fanny et on ira voir un
jour de semaine avec les tripes y est
les bouches et les volailles et tout le
monde va suivre le petit porteur de fut
un fait pour un moment a fait pour moi
et on va la mairie comme seul week-end
bons joueurs les mousquetaires sept ans
après j'avais 17 ans je peux plus
attendre il faut et le faut mais après
on verra j'en pense à propager
auguste le cantaloup ravaillac et
michaux robert qui fut lutte
yves jacques le sabre sans compter mon
ready monsieur pouillon aussi
et le type de bofa
ils fernand lavoie tort
c'était bien rincer lada
ce
[Musique]
mais voilà qu'elle se font la malle les
uns
[Musique]